now nearly 10 months after blm rioters
ransacked minneapolis the city
is bracing for more destruction jury
selection in the trial of derek chauvin
one of george floyd's alleged killers
is set to begin tomorrow and today's
proceedings were delayed after state
prosecutors sought to add a third
degree murder charge for chauvin city
and county officials are expecting
weeks of chaos and plan on spending
at least a million dollars on
fortifications around the city that
number's going up
but after a year of vilifying law
enforcement
are locals confident that well their
businesses
are going to be protected joining me now
are casey white
and charles stotts the owners of talk
diner and gastropub who watched their
business burn to the ground
last summer now casey it's good to see
you tonight i first met you
last august where you're standing right
now right in front of your diner
and i can see it's um well that's the
old photo but
old footage but i can see it's still not
standing behind you
uh today and there's your husband i
didn't have a chance to meet but
tell us what you're feeling ahead of
this trial
gosh you know i i definitely worry for
the city
with the trial coming up i mean
obviously it's something everyone's been
talking about for
some time now um there's the
conversation
that or you know that we do have more
security in the national guard here with
uh the trials beginning
but are is that going to be focused all
of the security
in downtown minneapolis where the trials
will be or
is it also going to be for the
surrounding neighborhoods that were
affected last summer with the rioting
charles the minneapolis police
department reported that homicides
soared 71 percent
last year that's a trend we've seen
across the country sadly
so again this trial is is going to get
underway
shortly and i've walked those streets i
talked to all those
incredible business owners but is there
enough fencing
to protect what's left of of minneapolis
and that particular part of the city
if things get out of hand given the
fewer number of police officers
enough fencing absolutely not the way i
see it
not only of homicides gone up crime and
violent crime
have both escalated in minneapolis last
year at this
time the research that i've done there
were 877
police officers that were active
in the city this year that number is
down to 638.
we have a police chief that's asking the
city council for
6.3 million dollars
to fill those spots the city council
says no
or at least uh is dragging
that process out when they submitted
their budget last december
they chopped 19 million dollars out of
the
police portion of the budget which
certainly would do
which would go towards some training so
as a city council
yeah this is unconscionable it is people
have to understand this like this is
minnesota nice minneapolis st paul
was one of the most i mean it is an
incredible place everyone knows i spend
a lot of time there especially in the
summer not the winner of the summer
i love it i was shocked to
i was shocked what i saw and
i was heartbroken for you casey because
you guys worked your tail off
to build your business and and people
who built a business they know it's
sweat from morning till night
and you're still a lot of people you're
still in ruins there
oh absolutely you know not just us other
businesses
as well oh
what what's next charlie what's next
what's next for you
well ideally
we want to you know get
get past this trial there's a
while the well mr floyd's death is
certainly at the forefront
of what it's going to take for some
things to heal in minneapolis and saint
paul
there's a lot of healing that still
needs to be done and i think it starts
by getting
the trial underway and getting this
behind us but
there's plenty of uh there's plenty of
secondary victims behind behind mr floyd
uh that the whole that we got to get
this world
and get our city rebuilt so we can yeah
get ourselves
back in operation yeah well we don't we
don't get to burn down
cities when we don't like the outcomes
of trials let's get that straight first
of all there's a lot a lot of trial
outcomes that a lot of us don't like but
you don't
have the right to burn down other
people's businesses as heartbroken
broken as you might be casey and charles
will be following this we'll check back
with you thank you both